[Aplausos]
hola buenas sales tijuana
me escuchan
me escuchan me voy
qué gusto qué privilegio deberás estar
aquí en shock como estado de salud
esta que va a ser usted aquí
ahora está dibujando si te puedes bajar
nada más
la verdad me emocioné o me emocionó
mucho estar aquí en tijuana he venido
varias veces me motivó mucho el hecho de
aceptar una plática para ted talks pero
me preocupo algo que tenía que hacer mi
plática de veinte minutos y hai cómo voy
a hacer eso porque normalmente las
prácticas que yo doy pues duran como un
minuto y medio
voy a tener que extender menos
y de hecho me gasté 20 segundos en ese
estúpido chiste
pero bueno me presento para la gente que
no me conoce soy omar chaparro para la
gente que ya me conoce pues también me
llamo igual soy omar chaparro
y bueno este soy soy de chihuahua
alguien de chihuahua
salte por favor irse es para tijuana no
tengo 28 años
no pierdo
como este verano cierto todos tenemos un
amigo que dice una estupidez y luego
después dice
es como es como un amortiguador para
decir algo fuerte es como si el papá
estoy embarazada
pero luego éste puede contestarme vale
madre eres alta
bueno
pongámonos serios por favor
soy administrador de empresas soy actor
soy comediante soy locutor soy
motociclista soy luchon de hecho he
hecho de todo prácticamente he sido
entero mesero taquero repartidor de
pizzas
entré al negocio de la ropa y de los
cacahuetes tengo tres hijos con mi
esposa lucy tengo 17 años de casados
y he hecho cine teatro televisión radio
pues como josé josé he rodado de acá
para allá básicamente
actualmente vivo en la ciudad los
ángeles california hace dos años me mudé
para allá con la intención de enfocar mi
carrera más en el cine no y bueno acá va
a ser una racha de cuatro películas y
una que se llama y como es el conamaq
mauricio ochmann y se no manches frida 2
hice una película en españa que se llama
los rodríguez y el más allá con rossi de
palma y la señora geraldine chaplin
acabo de filmar en londres una película
que se llama detective pikachu con ryan
reynolds
y la verdad si estoy pasando una buena
buena racha en un buen momento algunos
de ustedes dirán hay que que fácil no
que fácil lo que buena suerte y de hecho
para eso estoy aquí para decirles que no
es fácil y que la buena suerte no existe
pero les quiero compartir tres
herramientas que yo utilizo que me han
funcionado muchísimo para que no sea tan
difícil para que esa buena suerte que no
existe de alguna manera podamos
construirla
voy a remontar me cuando yo tenía 11
años estaba muy chiquito
más chiquito
la medicina así se llama se llama omar
chaparro es distinto pero lo hace sin
apellido así
tenía 11 años y mi papá don omar
chaparro pérez un hombre ranchero de
chihuahua viejo de grandote eba lagarto
con pantalón de mezclilla esas wrangler
esos mezclilla pesada que te la quitas y
los pones y que se quedan parados
pinches pantalones allí solos
y que siempre que se dirigía a mí me
decía juniors hasta la fecha me dicen
juniors con 43 años todas mis en juniors
y para siempre se rascaban güicho cuando
decía yúnes de juniors
por la mezclilla no sé es real
así como te vas
a ti no te dicen que abrió la vida
así me dice papá y a los 11 años mi papá
tenía un camión de transporte y me ponía
a lavarlo me acuerdo hacía frío había un
camión grandote en la noche tarde como
cuatro horas como pude y salió y me dijo
júnior anómico juniors
y lo que pasó a papá
que padre mío
y me dijo
el huevón trabaja doble
gracias no sabía qué quería decir lo que
quería decir es que el camión no había
quedado como él quería sus expectativas
y me hizo lavarlo perfectamente hasta
que quedara muy bien y entonces entendí
claramente que hay que hacer las cosas
bien muy bien desde el principio porque
si no va a ser más difícil porque
efectivamente el huevón trabaja doble y
se me quedó muy grabado eso eso que me
dijo mi padre
gabriela eres tú el gabriela es que no
no veo nada porque está la luz así veo
así como como puro zombies gabriela hace
una pregunta que sería más fácil para ti
gabriela si estás entrenando para el
maratón de chicago que vas a tener en
cuatro meses
pero del otro año es un universo
alternativo nomás ya sé que no corres si
corres si corredoras en esa platica de
aquí
gabriela que es más fácil para ti
levantarte al el sábado como a las 10 de
la mañana en sus pijamas hacerte unos
hot cakes con un capuchino está cruzado
con miel así tocino bien rico y luego
echarte a través a la cama o levantarte
el sábado a las 5 de la mañana a
prepararte correr 10 kilómetros en el
frío para el maratón que es más fácil
y los hot cakes levantarse a las 10 de
la mañana es fácil verdad pero según la
filosofía mi padre no porque si no te
levantaste a entrenar cuando estés en el
maratón de chicago en el kilómetro 8 vas
a estar vomitando y echando el pulmón
por la boca así idea muriendo ten o que
no te preparaste en ese momento vas a
entender que lo más fácil era haberse
levantado a las cinco de la mañana ahí
vas a entender que efectivamente el
huevón trabaja doble
necesitamos para poder correr el maratón
para poder terminar una carrera para
alcanzar el proyecto que queremos
para tener abundancia en nuestra vida
salir de la zona cómoda como dicen salir
de la zona de confort yo le llamo
ir en contra de nuestra naturaleza
huevona
nos da risa pero es realidad todos
venimos aquí no importa si naciste en
tijuana donde sea venimos en nuestro adn
con la naturaleza huevona implícita ahí
está porque siempre va a ser más fácil
quedarte a ver netflix con tu novia
entrepierna do que estudiar y desvelar
te hasta las 5 de la mañana esa
naturaleza web una es la que se encarga
de que tomemos las peores decisiones en
nuestra vida es esa vocecita que nos
dice está bien calentita las cobijas
ya han escuchado
esa vocecita que nos dice vámonos de
pedos mañana copias el examen
es real
esa vocecita es como es como las tres
mentiras del mexicano la última y nos
vamos mañana te pago y no más la puntita
analícenlo pero es real
yo empecé realmente a trabajar en
chihuahua en la radio en 1996 en
chihuahua chihuahua y comencé trabajando
sin goce de sueldo no me pagaba nada ya
era un morning show de de 6 de la mañana
a 10 de la mañana y de ahí me iba a
estudiar la carrera
dure un año así sin goce de sueldo que
horrible pero bueno luego nos empezamos
a volver famosos en chihuahua y vamos a
las escuelas y nos arrancaban las
playeras y los visitantes así se llama
el programa
terminé mi carrera en el 2000 y le dije
a mi mamá mamá papá
estoy listo ya me voy me voy a méxico
porque eso sí cuando alguien quiere ser
famoso o tener un éxito en el
espectáculo hoy día los jóvenes de hoy
pueden grabar un vídeo lo suben a
instancias se viral y pueden lograrlo
antes ya hace veintitantos años no pues
tenía que agarrar tu mochila y irte a la
capital y fue lo que hice con él fui me
acuerdo que le dije a mi mamá que me iba
para allá y esperaba las palabras de
cualquier mamá que reconforte a su hijo
no como hijo
alcanza tus sueños hijo que nada te
detenga
y se los juro que mi mamá me dijo algo
muy curioso que todo lo entiendo me dijo
juniors
ten cuidado con los homosexuales porque
son muy rencoroso
jajaja
no sé qué llevó a mi mamá a ese
pensamiento
en su cabeza pueblerina desigual igual
pues la capital
los artistas homosexuales [ __ ] se cogen
a mi hijo no
eso pensó en ella
el papá no me dijo nada no manejo
juniors
el huevón trabaja doble
total me fui llegué obviamente había
dejado un programa de radio había dejado
un programa de tele había dejado una
productora que yo había montado para
hacer comerciales y había renunciado a
un sueldo de gobierno del estado donde
hacían los comerciales
entonces lógicamente cuando me fui que
renuncia todos somos únicos estás loco
aquí bajas fijas df way
pero tenía lo que muchos de ustedes
tienen en este momento teníamos tenía
ganas tenía ganas de algo más de crecer
quería irme para allá
me fui llegué al df y se los juro las
avenidas y lo primero que hice fue
llorar
se los juro me solté llorando ahí en un
semáforo dijiste
todo el mundo vendiendo pan vasos y los
chilangos
los dos edificios eran no eran
chaparritos como en chihuahua no mucha
gente mucho tráfico contaminación allá
no había chiles y la consiguiente el
kilo
ahora nos deje que fregados y sé que
cualquier error cometí dios mío y pues
bueno me fui a frente dos cuartitos el
juego que mi hermana llegó y se soltó
llorando porque yo ahora como me gusta
ocupar
y así estuve seis meses me queda dormido
en la banqueta de televisa me metí de
extra y se me hice pasar por un
ejecutivo de multimedios en monterrey o
la recomendó marcha para bilateral
hice mil y una estupidez con tal de que
se me diera esa oportunidad tan anhelada
de entrar a la televisión
y a los seis meses que se me acabó el
dinero y se acabó algo más fuerte que el
dinero se me acabó la esperanza no tenía
nada y empecé a caer en depresión me
hablaba mi mamá juniors como está y yo
muy bien mamá
televisa no quería que la caída mi madre
no entonces desesperado y con el poquito
dinero que me quedaba compré una bolsa
de fruta y me disfracé de doña chole una
viejita que ayuda hacía que me
caracterizaba en mi natal chihuahua y
toque en la puerta de telehit canal de
cable y me abrieron los guardias de
seguridad ya los imaginaros como son
allá 190 jo azul
[Risas]
es lo que quieres
y se los juro yo veo el vestido de
anciana con una bolsa que no tenía
dinero ni sica para regresar me sabía
que era mi último tiro les dije soy la
abuelita el productor le traigo su
desayuno
que creen que pasó
me cerraron la puerta me di la vuelta
iba a ser lo que venía haciendo los
últimos tres meses que ayer a llorar
y me topé con el productor de telehit en
ese momento eduardo marrón y le dije soy
tu abuela
y me dijo algo que nunca se me va a
olvidar me dijo tan muy cargado y me
pasó a telehit y ahí realmente empezamos
a hacer un programa de televisión ahí
comenzó mi carrera en la televisión en
las grandes ligas por así decirlo un
programa que se llamaba black and white
alguien lo recuerda
porque me sucedió esto por tres razones
1 porque había salido de mi zona cómoda
habiendo en contra de mi naturaleza
huevo no se los dije porque si no
hubiera salido de esa zona cómoda pues
no ni siquiera me hubiera ido de
chihuahua a méxico o no me ahora
disfrazado de viejita
la otra razón porque me sucedió esto
porque lo había visualizado
porque le había dicho a mi mamá en
diciembre del 2000 y mi mamá me voy a ir
a méxico y en seis meses voy a entrar a
trabajar a la televisión y mi mamá dijo
ay pero los homosexuales llaman así
[Risas]
y así sucedió también le dije mamá en
tres años voy a hacer tanto ruido allá
que se ve escuchar hasta el último
rincón de chihuahua y en tres años
diciembre 3 de diciembre del 2003 se los
juro estaba ganando el reality show de
the big brother y fue todo un suceso
las cosas amigos siempre suceden dos
veces primero nuestra cabeza y después
en la vida real tiene que ser así
tenemos que imaginar como como dice
'chicharito' imaginemos imaginemos cosas
chingón as así es si no tienes un plan
del éxito en automático tienes un plan
del trabajo hay que imaginarse
visualizar funciona y por qué me sucedió
la tercera la tercera razón la tercera
herramienta porque me sucedió eso a mí
saben quién es este buster douglas
boxeador
muy bien
me sucedió porque yo tenía un porque
tenía hambre tenía deseo
tony robbins dice change is in es normar
of the lady is a matter of more y veis
jones el cambio no radica en la
habilidad sino en la motivación les ha
pasado cuando uno está motivado
entusiasmado no hay nada que nos detenga
tenía hambre tenía un porqué mí porque
es que le había prometido a mi novia mi
actual esposa hoy que iba a regresar por
ella y casarme no podía fallarle ese era
mi porqué buster douglas lo dijiste a lo
mejor no lo conocen muchos pero conocen
a mike tyson son los mejores boxeadores
de todos los tiempos peso completo
tenible nadie le había ganado invencible
y buster le tocó pelear contra mike
tyson obviamente las estadísticas todas
estaban a favor de mike tyson
en el octavo round va a ser douglas y va
perdiendo la pelea terriblemente mike
tyson lo noquea se cae y empieza la
cuenta regresiva
54 este tipo en el suelo con los ojos
casi en blanco porque mike tyson pegaba
como pata de mula
32 no se levanta uno se pone de pie
nunca antes en la historia un boxeador
que mike tyson había golpeado se había
levantado antes se levantó iba a
continuar la pelea pero la verdad estaba
lo cual noqueado pero de pie
mike tyson sabía y se abalanzó contra él
sonó la campana se salva noveno round
empieza la pelea
y nuevamente buster douglas estaba
contra las cuerdas contra el león mike
tyson
todos nosotros hemos estado alguna vez
contra las cuerdas sufriendo lastimados
es más levante la mano quien de aquí
no ha llorado en su habitación
todos hemos llorado en nuestra
habitación
todos hemos estado contra las cuerdas
porque nos corren de la escuela porque
porque nos corrieron del trabajo porque
me divorcié porque mi papá es alcohólico
porque yo que porque tuve un accidente
porque se murió un ser amado hemos
estado ahí
fracasados dolidos
la próxima vez que esté en contra las
cuerdas traten de hacer lo mismo que
hizo este señor douglas no dejó de tirar
un solo golpe no dejó de pelear siguió
peleando y finalmente noqueó a mike
tyson
nadie lo podía creer
pastel blanca mike tyson lo
entrevistaron va a ser como lo hiciste
con lo que hace al monstruo dice muy
fácil la respuesta es muy sencilla mi
mamá le ha dicho al mundo entero que yo
le iba a ganar a mike tyson
mi mamá dijo mi hijo como mi madre era
pariente miramar
era de chihuahua mi junior junior mano
clara a buster a mike tyson porque es
homosexual y está en coros
yo le dijo buster douglas mi mamá dijo
que yo iba a noquear a mike tyson así
que hizo una promesa
o me muero en el ring como mi mamá
o me levanto y noqueó a este cabrón y
vivo por ella
su porque era más grande que mike tyson
su porque era más grande que el campeón
y que las estadísticas
no sé cuál sea su sueño su proyecto pero
asegúrense que su porqué sea más grande
que cualquier cosa que levantarse a las
cinco de la mañana
que sea más grande que cualquier
pretexto que ese porque los motivos los
mueva que ese porque sea tan grande que
cuando vuelvan a estar en la lona
porque yo no lo quiera pero van a estar
la vida es así y nos va a tener en el
suelo y es doloroso cuando estén ahí que
su porqué sea tan grande que nos haga
querer levantarse a ganar la pelea
muchas gracias soy omar chaparro yo los
bendiga